constantemente las personas estamos
planteándonos metas replanteando otras
nos proponemos diferentes cosas el
gimnasio nuestra alimentación en general
tratamos de mejorar como persona y en
ese sentido yo quiero lanzarles un reto
a todas ya todos vamos a generar un
cambio cultural vamos a cuestionar el
concepto de aquello que entendemos por
ser hombre y quiero que sean honestas y
honestos quien de aquí está a favor de
la igualdad entre mujeres y hombres muy
bien la mayoría
quien está en contra de la violencia de
género
muy bien la mayoría y quien de aquí se
considera machista
casi nadie frases como
los niños no lloran pareces mujer
no seas [ __ ]
él paga porque es el hombre le pasó eso
por salir vestidas y por la noche son
frases que tenemos muy acuñadas ya a
nuestro lenguaje tan cotidiano que
vislumbra esa cultura machista que hemos
generado a través de la historia aunque
por supuesto pocas personas realmente
podríamos asumir nos como machistas
es normal parecería normal porque así
fuimos educados así se nos dijo que eran
las cosas las personas que más amamos
nos dijeron ciertas reglas y al momento
en el que alguien cuestiona esas ideas y
esas estructuras que hemos generado a
través de toda nuestra vida pues no nos
gusta que nos sentimos ofendidos y otras
veces ofendemos a mí me han llamado
mangín a
poco hombre entre otras cosas es más hay
incluso quien utiliza el término
feminista como un insulto
sin embargo la realidad es que estemos
conscientes o no o estemos de acuerdo o
no
la manera en la que se nos ha educado a
ser hombres nuestra masculinidad está en
crisis a ser hombre y a ser mujer en la
vida se aprende no es algo natural al
contrario de lo que podríamos pensar la
mayoría de la gente ya lo decía a simon
de beauvoir que a ser mujer no se nace
si no se llega a ser y lo mismo sucede
con los hombres desde que somos pequeños
se nos educa y prepara para hacer lo que
debemos ser en la vida ser hombre en
determinada cultura se nos dirá que no
podemos llorar que debemos ser fuertes
siempre rudos activos valientes se nos
potencian nuestras capacidades de manera
distinta que las mujeres incluso
nuestras acciones se valoran muy
distinto lo podemos ver en los medios de
comunicación a diario desde pequeños se
extiende a uniformizar nos
en este molde de la masculinidad
tradicional y nos quieren ver como
soldaditos todos muy parecidos desde que
somos pequeños se nos informa que ser
hombre es ser importante pero también se
nos impone una serie de cargas que
llevaremos hasta el último de nuestros
días de hecho esta serie de cargas
consiste en normas muy rígidas que
tenemos que cumplir por ejemplo número
uno tenemos que hacer los protagonistas
de hecho la masculinidad
se mide en el poder la riqueza y la
posición social
tenemos que ser fuertes como una roca
no podemos hacer gala de nuestros
sentimientos de hecho de ser posible no
mostrarlos a excepción de la del coraje
o la violencia mande los al [ __ ] que
nadie reten nuestra autoridad
tenemos que atrevernos
tenemos que arriesgarnos todo el tiempo
y otra muy importante que los hombres
nos construimos en oposición a las
mujeres no podemos hacer nada que
remotamente sugiera ser femenino
la idea de repudiar lo el apegarnos a
esta serie de normas nos ha permitido
acaparar el privilegio y el poder a
través de la historia controlamos el
ámbito político social económico
cultural sin embargo las mujeres
durante muchos años han generado cambios
en nuestra sociedad a través de lo que
yo considero el movimiento social más
importante del último siglo el feminismo
tan pacífico como incómodo ha venido a
cuestionar para siempre a la
masculinidad tradicional y la posición
de los hombres en la sociedad y eso nos
tiene muy enojados hemos gozado y vivido
el privilegio de manera plena
sin darnos cuenta ni percatarnos de los
efectos negativos que éste genera el
machismo afecta a las personas que nos
rodean y sin darnos cuenta nos afecta a
nosotros mismos nos acostumbramos rápido
a vivir dentro del machismo
comenzamos por sentir una carga cosas
que tenemos que cumplir y posteriormente
nos parecerá normal y así es como tiene
que ser que así es como se vive
podemos perder amigos
incluso nuestra propia familia
algunas veces terminan multa otras
en la cárcel y en casos
más extremos nos provocan nuestra propia
muerte la de nuestros seres queridos
porque el machismo genera una violencia
estructural
una violencia estructural en contra de
las mujeres una violencia estructural en
contra de los hombres una violencia en
contra de nosotros mismos 7 de cada 10
mujeres en méjico han confesado haber
sufrido algún tipo de violencia
psicológica económica física sexual
entre otras 7 mujeres a diario mueren a
causa de la violencia machista
y donde quedamos nosotros
las principales causas de muerte
en los hombres en méxico son los
accidentes viales porque manejamos
ebrios porque manejamos rápido porque
tenemos que atrevernos porque tenemos
que ser valientes son las agresiones
porque nos estábamos matando entre
nosotros a diario
y está el alcoholismo
porque ser alcohólico viviera
alcoholizado es un orgullo
y podemos observar como estas tres
principales causas de muerte están
directamente vinculados al ejercicio de
la masculinidad tradicional nos damos
cuenta como esta idea obsoleta de lo que
entendemos por ser hombre
se está desmoronando
las mujeres en sus esfuerzos tan
pacíficos nos han puesto el espejo de la
historia
y nos han obligado sin querer
a cuestionarnos quienes somos
qué es ser hombre hoy
soy machista
debo cambiar
soy libre por supuesto que entender y
asumir la igualdad conlleva a la pérdida
de privilegios y eso genera fuertes y
grandes resistencias inconscientes y
otras veces muy conscientes pero muy
evidentes todo el tiempo quien quiere
perder el privilegio
no nos gusta que nos disputa en nuestro
lugar el poder histórico sin embargo yo
los invito
a que tomemos esta oportunidad
y thom asumamos nuestra responsabilidad
y seamos
parte de una verdadera revolución de
género
si los hombres por ahí se preguntan por
dónde puedo empezar
yo les recomiendo cuestiones a sí mismos
la igualdad la haces tú y la hago yo
nadie va a caminar esos pasos por ti
aprende a escuchar a las mujeres
toma responsabilidad en el cuidado de
las personas de los niños de las niñas
de los ancianos ancianas enfermos
enfermas por un día a nuestras vidas
hagámonos a un lado y permitamos que una
mujer ocupe un espacio de poder y sea la
protagonista
cuidémonos amémonos también somos seres
excepcionales
amemos y reconozcamos a otros hombres
no quiero venderles el cuento de que yo
soy un hombre completamente transformado
a diario luchó por despojarme de esas
actitudes machistas y sexistas con las
que también crecí la clave está en
cuestionarse a diario
es hora de que abandonemos esa
masculinidad tóxica
de que hablemos de estas cosas con otros
hombres sin miedo es una deuda que
tenemos con las mujeres
es una responsabilidad que tenemos con
las próximas generaciones es una
urgencia sea con nosotros
y sólo hasta entonces podremos decir que
verdaderamente somos valientes fuertes
pero sobre todo personas libres
[Aplausos]